shout out to a mentor mind to try and  figure out if what i was doing was smart  because i felt like everything that i  was doing in terms of my investing in my  businesses was kind of countered  everyone else and he said this thing  that just pierced me to my soul he said  alex do you want to be in the one  percent and i was like yeah he was like  then stop caring about the other 99 are  doing because if you want to be in the  one percent it means that literally 99  of people are gonna be not doing what  you're doing and you just have to get  really comfortable with that because it  only gets rarer and the divide gets  wider as you go up the mountain